I'll be telling you about my paper with
sapara Sadi and Aaron Bernstein titled
all Norm load balancing in graph streams
of either multiplicative weights update
method
let me start by defining the load
balancing problem
so in the load balancing problem we're
given a bipartite graph on two types of
nodes
clients and servers
and every client comes with some
positive integer weight
okay the goal is to compute an
assignment
that is a mapping that sends each client
to one of its adjacent servers
sorts of the assignment is as balanced
as possible
okay so one way to capture balance is to
say you want to minimize the maximum
load of any server where the load of the
server is just the sum of the weights of
the client assigned to it so in this
case the first server has load 15
because it's assigned to three clients
of weight five
okay but this isn't the only way that
you might try to capture balance another
way to find a balanced assignment might
be to minimize say the sum of the
squares of the server loads or the L2
Norm of the server load vector
okay with respect to this objective
function the assignment on the right is
no longer optimal instead you'd want to
compute this assignment
and you'll note that this one has a
larger
minimum the maximum load of this
assignment is larger
so this example shows that in general
these two Notions are incompatible if
you minimize the L2 Norm
then you might not be optimal for the on
the min max objective which is also the
L Infinity Norm and vice versa
okay but it turns out that it is
possible to be approximately optimal for
both of these objective functions
simultaneously
in fact something much stronger is true
you can be approximately optimal for all
LP Norms all P Norm objective functions
simultaneously we call this when you try
to find such a simultaneously
approximate the optimal assignment we
call this the L this sorry the all Norm
objective function
or the unknown objective
okay so more precisely I'll say that a
an assignment is a beta all Norm
assignment if it's a beta approximation
for all Alpine arms simultaneously
and it was shown about 20 years ago by
azer Epstein Rector and vogen gear that
there always exists a two all normal
assignment and moreover you can find
this assignment in polynomial time
okay the lower bound front
it's NP hard to find a better than three
halves approximation
even if you only hear about the L
Infinity Norm
okay so we study this load balancing
problem and focus on the all-norm
objective
uh in the semi-streaming model
so let me just quickly Define the semi
streaming model so here the edges of the
input graph arrive one by one in a
stream and the algorithm has to process
these these edges using only o till then
space so in particular it can't store
the entire graph if the graph is
sufficiently dense
the goal is to solve the desired problem
using just a few passes over the Stream
the fewer the passes the better
in our case we're going to take about
login passes and compute an assignment
that has good guarantees
okay so what's known about this this
problem this load balancing problem the
semi-screening model
S as far as I know there's only been one
other paper that's explicitly studied
this this problem it's By Conrad and
Rosen and they were focused just on the
unweighted uh
they're focused on unweighted clients
and the L Infinity Norm objective
and they showed that
in one pass you can get a squared down
approximation
which is still the best known
and in login passes you can get you can
bring the approximation ratio down to
login down to a login approximation
and there's some smooth trade-off uh in
between here as well
okay we showed that if you're if you
spend login passes to process the stream
you can actually do much better and kind
of improve all of these parameters so
you can bring the in login passes you
can bring the approximation ratio down
to constant
and you get a constant approximation for
all the lp Norms simultaneously
including the L Infinity Norm
and our algorithm also works for
weighted clients
so we can be seen as a strict
Improvement of this second result
okay so let me tell you about our
approach so
the higher order bit is in the title of
the talk and the paper which is that we
use the multiplicative weights update
method so in order to apply the
multiplicative way to update method if
we first have to formulate our problem
as a convex program or set a bunch of
convex constraints
um
so here's the beta all Norm load
balancing convex program
we have a decision variable for every
Edge whether or not we're using that
edge to assign the client
to that server via that edge
starting from the bottom and
these middle constraints
say that we should assign every client
at least once
again if you assign a client more than
once of course you can redo you can
improve the solution by bringing it down
so this could be equality but it's just
more convenient to create it as an
inequality
okay in the top constraints um there's
actually
infinitely many even uncountably many
um
these are our LP Norm constraints they
say that the lp Norm of the fractional
assignment that we compute should be no
more than a Copley beta which will shoot
for a constant beta times the optimal uh
possible value for that P
okay and it's important to note that
these constraints up top are convex so
the multiplicative weights framework
does apply here
okay I'll just rewrite this top
constraint by raising everything to the
P power
to make it look a little simpler and now
the way we use the multiplicative ways
framework is we kind of relax these
middle constraints so rather than
solving
um
this convex program and satisfying all
of these constraints for each client
we instead just have to solve this
Oracle problem that's given to us by the
multiplicative waves framework let me
Define that now so
um
basically we introduce a distribution
over those constraints so p is our
distribution over those those client
constraints
and rather than solving each of the
rather than satisfying each of those
constraints we just need to satisfy
those constraints on average
again the multiplicative weight's
theorem says that
if you can solve this problem if you can
produce an oracle for this problem
then there's an algorithm the
multiplicative weights algorithm
just you know tailored to LPS
that will produce an approximately
feasible problem to the original sorry
approximately feasible solution to the
original problem
okay and the amount of invocations that
the algorithm makes to this Oracle
is going is going to depend on some
parameter called the width which is
basically the maximum amount of
violation that uh you make with respect
to any of the original constraints
okay so we only have to satisfy the
constraints on average but we also don't
want to violate them by too much or
we'll pay in the width parameter
and what the the multiplicative waves
theorem says is if you can solve this
problem
let's find the point always be able to
find a point that's feasible for this
um then after just
let me write it here
in order
um
rho squared login over Epsilon squared
invocations to the oracle
we can produce an assignment because we
can produce an X that satisfies this so
we just get a kind of an additive
Epsilon error here
okay so for us we need row to be
constant in order for
um the login passes to work because
we're going to implement each Oracle
call by one Passover the Stream
and once we find a fractional assignment
that satisfies all of these constraints
we can just do some rescaling and apply
a standard rounding algorithm
to produce an integral assignment
okay so the the kind of the upshot from
this whole section
uh is that we just we've reduced our
problem to this beta all Norm problem
and if we can solve this problem with
constant width in let's say a constant
number of passes we'll only need one
pass actually to solve this problem over
the stream then we get a login pass
algorithm for the all Norm assignment
problem
load balancing problem
okay
so let me now start telling you how we
actually solve this problem but I'll
I'll just focus in the case of
unweighted clients
um just just to keep the toxic
okay so a couple quick definitions
so I wanted to find a matching hierarchy
first let me Define a 1D matching
so 1D matching is just a set of edges
such that every client's incident to at
most
uh one Edge that's what the first
Runner says and every server is incident
in most D edges
okay so this is just a b matching where
I'm splitting up the capacities of the
Surfers and clients and servers
okay and then I'll Define a matching
hierarchy
as a sequence of matchings from m0 to ml
where Mi is a 1 2 to the I matching
and the matchings are all nested
Okay so
maybe I'll try to draw a picture so
um
you might have just some edges m0
then in M1 you'll use all of those edges
again but you're also allowed to add
some other Edge to uh to servers the
servers can have capacity to in M1
okay and so on so that's a matching
hierarchy
all right it'll also be useful to kind
of break down the cost of an assignment
the lp Norm of an assignment
um and charge that cost to the clients
so let me explain how that works now on
the the example on the right I guess I'm
looking at the L2 Norm squared
so the first server has load three so
it's contribution to the L2 Norm squared
is nine next one's load two so
contribution is four so the sum of these
things is just the L2 Norm squared
um
we're going to distribute the cost of
each server among its clients by just
ordering its clients
[Music]
um
let's say arbitrarily for now and
basically assigning each client
the cost so that it I guess we think of
the clients as come as being assigned
one at a time
and every time you assign a new client
we charge it the amount that it
increased that server's contribution so
when you sign the first client the
server is contributing one to the L2
normal squares of that client gets
charged one or meet assign the second
client the servers contribution will be
opened up to four so we should charge
this client three and so on okay so the
more formal
descriptions here on the right so we're
always going to charge the first client
one
to be I guess
um and then we'll always charge the KF
client just the amount that it increased
the server's contribution to the lp Norm
LP Norm to the paid power
okay so this will be a useful scheme to
keep in mind
uh I also want to talk about a matching
hierarchy decomposition so we Define
matching hierarchies uh just through
their slide if we're given an assignment
we can decompose it into a matching
hierarchy
um
in a simple way we just take let's say
the first client
uh of every server first client assigned
to every server that'll form our
matching m0
if we take the first two clients
assigned to every server
that forms
M1 and if we take the first four clients
assigned to every server
that'll give us uh M2 and in this case
we have handled
all of the clients
okay now let me tell you about something
called the matching hierarchy
decomposition
so we can decompose
um an assignment a into a matching
hierarchy in a kind of the obvious way
so we just take the first client
assigned to each server
that forms a matching
and zero
then we can take the first two clients
assigned to every server
that'll form a 1 2 matching M1
and so on the next one will be a
a 1 4 matching
and that forms our matching M2
okay and these are nested
um
okay so what's the point of forming this
matching heart it really gives us a way
to
approximate this cost you know the cost
next to the clinch right now that's an
exact cost of the servers
um in the analysis it's you know because
of our algorithm of computer matching
hierarchy actually
we just need a way to approximate the
cost of an assignment built from this
matching hierarchy
or the mastering hierarchy decomposition
of an assignment actually so okay this
is a pretty messy expression but
um what this is trying to say here is
that
um this should actually be a p
the P Norm of the assignment raised to
the P power
is sandwiched between two terms that are
basically the same up to a two to the P
Factor so this term on the left
and this term on the right the only
difference is the what term on the right
has a
extra 2 to the P the factor in there
okay more or less what this what this is
saying is if we take the decline cost
here in this L2 Norm example rather than
charging them 135 I could have charged
them one two four and if there was
another client assigned to that server I
would also charge this one for
uh and these ones would get charged one
two and one this would uh
be an underestimate for the L2 Norm
squared
whereas if I doubled all of these
quantities I would get an overestimate
for the L2 orange squared
so that one would have had cost seven
and we would charge at eight
okay so it's
uh just giving us this simple formula
okay I'm just summing them in kind of a
funny way but it'll be convenient
basically a
yeah you can just take a second and
pause to to see that this
um
this quantity is actually summing the
ranks the clients the way I described it
okay
so now we kind of have a criteria for a
good all alarm assignment where we can
we can sorry we can devise a good create
the criteria for a good all Norm
assignment
so if we have some partial assignment a
and uh let's say a matching hierarchy
decomposition of it we'll think of this
as something like the algorithm computes
and we have another uh we want to
compare ourselves to say the optimal a
star and have a matching hierarchy
decomposition of that
then I claim there's basically these two
criteria you need in order to
assert that the load is good so that the
so basically if these two red conditions
hold
then the lp Norm of this assignment
is
basically at most two times the lp Norm
of a if you just raise everything to the
one over p
okay we can pretty much ignore this
Alpha it's only helping us
okay so why is this true I can give a
try to give a quick proof of this so
we can write the load of a
by the Bound in the previous slide
this is at most two to the
[Music]
um
P times I Plus 1.
times M log n
minus MI
and let me just write this actually
like this since they're nested this is
equivalent
now we apply the two inequalities so
both of the inequalities are going in
the right direction
so I can basically substitute in the M
stars and pull out an alpha term of one
over Alpha term in fact
so this is less than or equal to let me
pull out
um 2 over Alpha
times 2 to the
P times I
times
M Star log n minus
M Star I
but now this term is just what we saw on
the other side the lower bound
so this is less than or equal to
the load of a star
okay so basically we're trying to find a
matching hierarchy or or a partial
assignment who's matching how it
satisfies these two conditions this
first condition
says that all of the matchings are
relatively large like an alpha
approximation
and this one says that at the same time
we don't have that many edges
um
the total number of edges we use should
be at most of one over Alpha fraction of
however many
and our Optimus and if we think about
um the actual optimal assignment they
star this right hand term is just n
is the optimal assignment matches all
the clients
Okay so
we want a matching hierarchy that has
this but this isn't quite enough because
we also need to make sure that we
accumulate enough of the the probability
Mass
so there's one additional constraint so
I just collect these on the next slide
we want a partial assignment
whose decomposition satisfies these
speakers so these are the two criteria
from the last slide we also have this
new Criterion which says that the mass
should be large enough
and if we have a partial assignment
that's that that meets these criteria
then we just can take it's like
indicator vector
let's say 1A
and scale it up by an alpha Factor then
we would meet this bottom like this
bottom inequality implies that we would
meet the original inequality which was
that the sum of the masses of the
clients is at least one
and we would only hurt our LP Norm by an
alpha Factor by doing this rescaling
so if Alpha is a constant we're okay so
we need we want to solve the basically
find a matching hierarchy that satisfies
this
for uh constant Alpha
okay
um
so I'll tell you how we do this now
although I'll omit the proof that it
actually satisfies these three things
you can check the paper for those
details
[Music]
um
the
basically the the key idea is that we
can form a matching hierarchy like this
using some greedy algorithm
okay and it's partially inspired by
um this idea of craption stubs that
compute um
so Craftsman Subs had an algorithm to
compute
um
basically large matchings like Alpha
proc or four approximate
matching roughly
um
in the semi-streaming model in one pass
and what they do is they partition all
of the edge weights into these nested
buckets and compute macro matchings in
each of them and then do some greedy
combination
okay we do something uh very similar
here so we partition the clients into
these nested classes
so in this picture c0 is the Class
Appliance that have mass at least one
half each client has mass at least one
half so this picture is clearly wrong
because I put three clients in that
bucket
um
the next one has mass at least a quarter
and and so on
and then in each of these classes if you
want to build like a large matching
let's just say a one matching first we
uh
grab like a maximal matching maybe here
then in the next uh class which contains
the previous one so for C1
so C1 is this entire thing
we also compute a maximum matching
which I won't continue to draw
and at the end of computing all these
matchings for all these classes we just
combine them in the greedy way prefer
starting with c0 and then augmenting
with C1 and augmenting from the edges we
found from C2 and so on
and you can show that this thing when
you compute such a matching
by maximality you originally lost maybe
half of the edges and then you lose
another factor of two
um so you can show that the matchings
that you get here are at least
um
a quarter of the best possible matching
you could have got
okay in addition to that these types of
matching will also accumulate a lot of
mass so they're not just large in size
but they they have these two properties
that they kind of have large weight but
also large cardinality
okay so now I can finally State the
the algorithm
um so inspired by that last slide so
this thing I'm boxing now is basically
the previous slide and parallel over the
Stream
you compute a matching of each of those
different classes and also each eye
because we're going to use it remember
computer matching hierarchy
this this step will use like we we're
basically Computing log squared
and of these different matchings
and this is the only uh thing we need to
stream for so we just compute a bunch of
maximal matchings in one pass and then
everything happens as a post-processing
step the rest of this algorithm
so the next thing is is more is
basically greedy merging so we do two
types of greedy merges which I haven't
exp expanded in the slide one's the one
I talked about on
the the last Slide the the Crouch dubs
type of greedy matching or sorry greedy
merging
then we do another type of greedy
merging because once we do that we get a
bunch of
um one two to the eye matchings we have
to form them into a nested matching
hierarchy at this point they're not
nested so we do one more kind of round
of merging to
Force these things into a nested
matching hierarchy
and we lose another factor of two in the
process
okay so at the end of this thing we got
a nested matching hierarchy where MI
is at least an eighth of Mi star
we don't have the additional property
here yet that M log n is is at most n
over 8.
okay that's kind of handled implicitly
by the rest of the algorithm so then in
the rest of the algorithm we just try to
extract a good partial assignment from
uh this matching hierarchy
and the and the matching hierarchy
decomposition of the partial assignment
that we extract will satisfy the
conditions we had on the previous uh a
few slides ago
okay so what the algorithm does is it
basically
[Music]
um
I'm pausing because I just realized that
these uh for Loops are in the wrong
order
um so this should be a j and this should
be an I sorry about that
so first we look at the largest kind of
weight like the mass class the things
that that are going to help us do the
covering constraint the most
and then we iterate over our matchings
from lowest Mi to largest Mi and we
start greedily adding edges to our
assignment until we collect exactly a
one over Alpha fraction where Alpha here
is eight because of uh
what I said before so once we have
exactly I want a fraction of the clients
then
um
it would basically be done with this J
iteration this either sorry this J
iteration we move to the next J
iteration
Okay so I encourage you to go to look at
the paper where we explain this in a
little bit more detail
[Music]
um
but at the end of the algorithm we just
returned the indicator for this
assignment scaled up and prove that this
satisfies the uh there's a solution to
the beta all Norm Oracle
problem
okay
so
um
let me just conclude so this was our
main theorem
that there's a login pass let me
streaming algorithm to compute a
constant approximate all-term assignment
for the client weighted load balancing
problem
some interesting questions for future
work
are basically going to reduce the number
of passes we don't really know that much
about
um
the one pass setting for example uh the
best we know is a squared ad
approximation it's a relatively simple
algorithm
and there aren't really any substantial
lower bounds
just no nothing just
I'm sorry maybe just two you you can't
beat a two approximation
um
okay so thank you